Leute ganz kurz wie gebe ich mir die
barrierblöcke das sind ja diese
unsichtbaren Blöcke damit kann ich
Sandra einbauen
[Musik]
so
dieses Moment
wie lange ist schon Minecraft bin ich
gerade reingegangen sandra ist noch
nicht mal auf dem Server untereinander
auch noch nicht auf dem Server ist habe
ich gerade die Chance genutzt mir 64
barrier zu geben barrier ganz kurz zur
Infos sind und sichtbare Blöcke das
heißt ich werde sag mal wenn sie auf dem
Server ist ablenken damit einbauen und
dann schauen wie sie reagiert
wir haben natürlich auch noch genug zu
tun hier und zwar die Tierfarm die würde
ich jetzt erstmal so grob andeuten
und danach dann die immer mehr ein
bisschen schöner machen weil das soll
jetzt auch keinen ich hatte mir da so
ein paar Sachen angeguckt im Internet
ich hole mir immer Inspiration bisher
ähm die Sache ist allerdings dass das
alles nur so riesige Projekte waren und
das hier soll ja schon relativ offen
sein weil wir hatten ja gesagt dass das
hier so eine Tierfarm werden soll wo wir
jetzt nicht irgendwie große Gebäude hier
hin bauen sondern ich möchte ja wenn wir
hier drin stehen dass wir von hier dann
die Tiere sehen können und so ein
bisschen hier rüber gucken können hier
vorne der Blick gleich bleibt deswegen
kommt hier einfach jetzt erstmal so ein
paar Gehege hin welche Tiere seht ihr
das Schweine Kühe Schafe Pferde Hühner
Hunde
Katzen weiß ich nicht Schildkröten okay
schreibt sie unten in die Kommentare die
Leute schreiben im Chat warum dass ich
dich mal küssen soll junge im Leben
nicht hörst mich doch jetzt
komm her ein Schmatzer danke auch nicht
in MC junge aber warum bleibt genau da
stehen ich komme jetzt
[Musik]
danke genau da stehen
cool oder hallo
du kannst ihn ja von immer so aus Holz
machen und du kannst auch mal Gemälde an
die Wand hängen man kann ja auch Bilder
machen in Minecraft Leute ganz kurz Info
ich kann den prank nicht machen mit dem
Barrien solange Sandra da unter Wasser
ich muss irgendwie am besten Fall
irgendwie mal oben stehen da so in ihrem
Haus dann sagen hey Leute ich muss mal
kurz was googeln und ich muss mal kurz
los oder irgendwie so weißt du dass wir
das sinnvollste
nein hey was war das denn das sind
unsere Latern warum baust du denn unsere
Laternen ab das habe ich nicht gecheckt
[Musik]
was ist das denn jetzt hier hä
ich komme raus hey
geh doch einfach vor
oder was meinst Du ich laufe doch auch
rum das geht nicht
was ich komme runter
[Musik]
was machst du da Ding was habe ich was
ist das
ich sehe gar nichts auf das ist ein ähm
das sind barrierblöcke heißen die das
sind unsichtbare Blöcke und damit kann
man Sachen einbauen und kann da nicht da
lang laufen und so so die Barrieren
Blöcke weg damit hier nichts
was ist los
mir ist eine scharf entflohen
hey Flo aber nicht gestorben
[Musik]
ich habe doch Weizen in der Hand ein
paar Sekunden später tschüss machs gut
ich liebe dich und deine Eltern dass ich
geboren haben Ciao Handy
es ist nicht nur ein Schaf wenn Flo
sondern zwei
Flo nein dir nein
unser Bauer
danke
sie macht immer einen später bitte den
Eingang
was sollst du denn noch haben
[Musik]
der Eingang der hier ist soll hier sein
nee nicht da
da genau also Leiter hoch okay
[Musik]
ja
warum fehlt mir Glas
was nicht keine Ahnung
irgendwie sind unsere Gemälde voll viel
eine ein Creeper gemeldet die was ja
guck mal ich komme rein die Gemälde sind
fertig
die Gemälde
ja
gemelde
Gemälde
[Musik]
hier nicht gemelde
wie denn Gemälde
Gemälde
Gemälde Sprachen lernen
du musst mich erstmal einladen hier so
richtig rein okay
ja komm rein
[Musik]
mit einem Bus
hier nochmal dasselbe ah das haben sie
zweimal gekauft richtig hier
ein großer Creeper
gekauft weil ich Geld habe
zwei Creeper zwei Creeper Mini Creeper
großer Creeper Mini Creeper großer
Creeper okay und das ist keine Ahnung
ich erkenne da nichts drauf das haben
sie einfach so gekauft weil sie reich
sind
welches Bild darf ich Ihnen abkaufen
[Musik]
ja ich habe uns einen Bunker gebaut ich
komme nicht mehr runter
doch wo denn wie man das Bild rechts
rein
[Musik]
krass ne
wie geht das denn man kann einfach eine
Tür hinsetzen wenn man dann die Tür
aufmacht kann man auf den Rand von der
Tür richtig machen mit einem Bild und
dann kann man so ein Geheimgang machen
wenn ultimate Venom noch mal kommen
haben wir jetzt versteckt
auf jeden Fall einige deswegen kommen
die müssen weiter nach hinten hier hin
das nicht direkt am Weg darum Gedränge
ist
das sind doch wirklich solche Trottel
oder
Laser wir sehen uns morgen ne du gehst
offline ja ich gehe jetzt auch raus aus
Minecraft wir sehen uns morgen der Laser
wir sehen uns morgen bei Podcast ciao
ciao ciao ciao also Leute folgt mir auf
Instagram at Laser Luca da kündige ich
Streams immer als erstes an ansonsten
auch hier auf Twitch gerne rein Folgen
ist kostenlos und ihr werdet
benachrichtigt sobald ich live gehe ich
wünsche euch einen wunderschönen Abend
und wir sehen uns morgen im neuen
Youtube Video wieder
[Musik]